In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Sinoxadion for May 28, on which we commemorate, are venerable
Father Andrew, the fool for Christ.
Our Holy Father Andrew was a slave of Scythian Slavic origin, who lived in Constantinople
in the service of a dignitary of the Imperial Guard, Protopatharios.
He quickly learned both sacred and secular arts and was the admiration of all those around
him for his learning.
One night, as he was praying, he saw with fear an army of Ethiopians ready to fight
a detachment of white men, called to engage in single-handed combat against the champion
of the barbarians, Andrew knocked him to the ground, and in recompense received three crowns
from an angel.
While Christ, appearing in the form of a young man, said to him,
fight this good fight, naked, and become a fool for me, and become worthy of the kingdom
of heaven.
As soon as day broke, Andrew, obeying this divine command, began his career as a fool
for Christ by cutting his tunic with a sword, and uttering great cries, which frightened
all the household.
His master, judging that he was possessed, had him put in chains and kept at the church
of Saint Anastasia, Farmacolitria.
There he passed his days, feigning madness by all sorts of eccentricities by day, and praying
all night long.
One night he was assailed by a horde of demons, but as soon as he called on Saint John the
theologian to help him, the apostle appeared with a roar of thunder, dispelled the demons
with the chains that held Andrew, and promised the Saint his enduring help in all his battles.
In another nocturnal vision he was called to serve a king in his palace, and received snow
to eat, which was transformed into a heavenly fragrance.
Then he was offered bitter fruits, a symbol of the narrow path that was his, and afterwards
exquisite food was given to him, which sent him into a divine ecstasy.
On being freed after the four months of captivity, Andrew began publicly to imitate the conduct
of Simeon the fool, yet while Simeon would use irony and derision under the cover of
folly to condemn sinners and the vain vanities of this world.
Andrew, by his facetious foolishness, offered himself to scorn and ill-treatment, in imitation
of Christ, to show forth the folly of the cross, applying to the letter the words of the apostle
who said, we are fools for Christ.
He offered himself voluntarily to derision and blows, and made himself the filth of the
world, the offscoring of humanity.
In order to gain the kingdom of heaven and encourage others to enter it.
Going one day into a house of ill-repute, he was protected by divine grace, and remained
immovable in the face of provocation by the prostitutes, who finally stripped him of
his clothes and chased him away.
Dressed only in a straw-dormat, which from then on became his habitual dress, he would wander
the streets homeless and would hand on to the poor the alms he was given.
He never asked for food, making do with half a dry loaf a day, and often not eating for
whole weeks at a time.
To quench his thirst, he would lap at the edges of muddy puddles, an indecency that made
passers-by indignantly kick and swear at him.
At night he would lie down with the stray dogs.
One winter night, as he tried to snuggle close to one of them to find some warmth, the animal
moved away with disdain.
To offer himself to this total dereliction was, for the blessed man, a source of delight,
but prayer never left his lips.
A sort of bubbling in his mouth could always be seen like that of the apostles on the day
of Pentecost.
When he prayed at night, he was often raised from the earth, and his spirit would find itself
ravished in ineffable ecstasy.
On the very same night, on which even the dogs rejected him, he was transported to God
in ecstasy, and being delivered from the weight of the flesh was clothed in a luminous tunic,
and crowned like a king.
He found himself in the midst of a wonderful garden full of heavenly plants and golden birds
in the center of which was a large, luxuriant vine, bearing grapes of an extraordinary size,
and angel then led him above the firmament to a place of indescribable beauty, in which
he saw the cross surrounded by four veils.
Another angel led him to a higher place, where he gazed on two crosses like the first.
Then he was taken to the third heaven, which only St. Paul had been judged worthy to see before
him, where he contemplated three crosses, brilliant as lightning, surrounded by a heavenly
army that was praising God.
He passed beyond a veil of linen and porphyry, and came to an even more resplendent place,
where there was an uncountable assembly of young men, more luminous than the sun.
An angel lifted the last veil, and Andrew was able to contemplate the throne of God,
suspended, unsupported in the air, from which a white flame came forth.
Christ was seated there, and he dimmed his glory for a moment so that Andrew might rejoice
for a single instant in the splendor of his divino-human reality, and he then became invisible.
A voice sweeter than honey than pronounced three times, three mysterious divine names,
and immediately the saint was taken back to the garden, where he met a radiant man holding
across.
Who blessed him and said, Blessed are you, you fools, for you possess a great wisdom.
May the crucifixion of our Lord Jesus Christ be with you.
He then sent him back to the earth, with the mission of overturning the prince of this
world by voluntarily taking human derision and persecution upon himself.
Resuming his folly with renewed boldness, Andrew made the acquaintance of Epiphanius a young
18-year-old aristocrat who was chaste and gentle.
He became his protector and spiritual son, and Andrew prophesied to him that he would
become patriarch of Constantinople.
Welcome to Epiphanius' house to live, he began to denounce the sins of the servants who
came from several different nations, in parables, uttered in their own tongues.
He refused the bed offered by Epiphanius and spent his nights outside on the dung heap.
Nor did he hesitate to resume his custom of wandering through the streets, exposing himself
to the cruel escapades of ruffians and to the blows of passers-by.
When he had addressed people, he would always call them fools or madmen, but he also constantly
condemned himself with the greatest humility.
During a further vision of the evil one and his demon troops, when the demons approached
him for having led those who had been in their power to repentance by revealing their sins
to them by his prophetic acts, Andrew began a violent argument with the prince of darkness,
yet the latter had no power over the man of God, for he had stripped himself of all earthly
attachment.
One night the demon made him fall into a pit, but as soon as the saint called upon Saint
Peter and Paul, the two apostles appeared and drew him out of the murky depths, while
a luminous cross appeared and guided him for the rest of his journey.
During a great epidemic of plague that broke out in the capital, the saint passed up and
down the streets, weeping and interceding for the city and asking God to forgive the people's
sins, and this despite the mockeries heaped upon him by certain idolers.
As he prayed, he was transported to Anoplas on the Bosphorus, where he met Saint Daniel
the Stylite, who suggested that they unite their prayers for the salvation of the city.
A fire suddenly descended from heaven and cast out the demon that had provoked the epidemic.
Saint Andrew did not cease to reproach sinners, both by warnings and by predicting their coming
punishment, a punishment that never failed quickly to come to pass.
Walking one day in front of Stahl's laden with luxury goods in the market, he cried out,
straw and rubbish.
Another time at the malicious suggestion of passing jokers, he began to gobble up the fine-fresh
figs laid out on the stall of the green grocer while the ladders slept.
When the green grocer awoke and surprised the saint in the act, he seized a stick and
began to rain down blows on him.
Andrew led himself be struck without resistance, and then proclaimed that, if he had been struck
because of his gluttony, how much more would sinners who did not repent receive eternal
punishment from God?
Having received the gift of reading the souls of others, he denounced the hypocritical piety
of those who stood in church entertaining worldly thoughts in their heads, or who would
sing from vain glory and ostentation.
He was able to distinguish the demons of indifference, sloth and acidia, which suggested to their victims
that they should leave the church before the end of the service.
At the end of Lent, he was able to discern the spiritual state of each.
He would see virtuous people crowned and clad in fine linen, and sinners with vile and
filthy insects covering their garments.
Yet, his first care was the spiritual education of Epiphanius, the only person with whom he spoke
in a sensible manner.
He instructed him masterfully in the battle against the demons, and sometimes led him be tempted
by them so that he might acquire patience and become through the fire of trials bread
worthy of God.
He also taught him about the mysteries of creation, the spiritual world, and above all, what would
happen at the end of time, when, after terrible trials, invasions and natural calamities, the
emperor of the Romans would go and put his crown on the cross in Jerusalem before it was carried
up to heaven by an angel.
In this way, the time of the Christian Empire inaugurated by St. Constantine would be brought
to fulfillment.
A short time afterwards, Constantinople, which the Byzantines of that time often considered
to be an eternal institution, would be engulfed in the waves of the sea, just like Babylon.
And Jewish sovereignty would be re-established in Jerusalem.
All would come to believe in the Antichrist, who would reign as only sovereign on earth and
would persecute the Christians.
Christ would then appear to lead the great battle against the Antichrist, and, when he had
been conquered, Christ would take him and his demons before the judgment seat of God, while
a trumpet would sound, announcing the resurrection of the dead.
After the judgment, four angels would hold the four corners of the universe, and they
would roll it up at the Lord's command.
The whole universe would thus be renewed.
The new heaven and the new earth would appear.
A new world worthy of the incorruptible bodies of the risen.
Everything would thus be incorruptible and eternal, and the beauty of an indescribable fragrance
would fill the whole universe, which would be illumined by an endless day, without evening.
One day, when Andrew and Epiphanios had gone to the church of the blacker nay, for the
vigil that took place each week, they saw the most holy mother of God, moving forward from
the holy doors, escorted by a great multitude of saints, among whom were to be found St. John
the Baptist, and St. John the Theologian, uncovering the people with her veil.
On another occasion, as St. Andrew was reading a text of St. Basil's to his disciple, a heavenly
fragrance drifted around them.
Replying to Epiphanios' question, the saint revealed that this fragrance was taken by the
angels from the throne of God to honor humans on three occasions.
When they pray, when they read the holy scriptures, and when they suffer patiently for the love
of God, sometime after these revelations about the end of time, St. Andrew told Epiphanios
of his approaching death.
He forbade him to institute the celebration of his memory or to keep his relics.
Or he had made a vow before God never to be glorified on earth.
He again prophesied that Epiphanios would be elected patriarch and promised that he would
always invisibly assist him, on condition that he showed solicitude towards the poor, widows,
orphans, and all those under trial.
He then went to the hippodrome, to the portico where the prostitutes were wont to gather,
and there prayed all night long for the whole world.
His prayer completed, the blessed one laid down on the ground, and watching with a smile
the large crowd of saints who had appeared to help him, gave his soul into God's hands
after 66 years of ascetic striving hidden under the veil of madness.
A poor woman who lived nearby, drawn by the strong scent of incense, ran and discovered
his body.
But when the crowd informed by the woman rushed to the spot, the saint's body had disappeared,
carried by God to an unknown place.
That night Epiphanios saw the soul of his spiritual father seven times more luminous than
the sun, lifted up to heaven, surrounded by the presence of myriads of angels, through
the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save
us.